(musiikkia)
No terve, tämmönen uusi, ilmeisesti uusi, uudehko. Niin urheilutermi kuin nälkäinen. Sillä ilmeisesti tarkoitetaan sitä, että haluaa voittaa.
Ja minne on häipynyt semmoinen sana kuin voitontahto? Ja että on voimakas voitontahto. Minne semmoinen on häipynyt? Nälkäinen on kyse siitä, että laitetaan jotain tonne nenään alle olevaan reikään. Syödään jotain. Jos on nälkä, niin silloin syödään. Urheilusta pois tämmönen nälkäinen. Voitonta tilalle, kiitos.
Jälleen on aika toivottaa perinteisti, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Puoli tuntissa on luvassa ainakin asiaa liikenteestä, työstä ja musiikista. Tällä kertaa ohjelman osaset on laskenut kohdilleen Koiviston Lauri. Yksi kanslainen kehottaa laittamaan terveyspolitiikalle suitset. Toisen mielestä työttömien pitäisi mennä poimimaan marjoja. Ja kaivataanpa myös vanhoja autoja takaisin.
Nyt lähdetään kävelylle!
Me menemme nyt liikenneasioita kohti. Kävelyn lisäksi muitakin kulkemistapoja on luvassa.
No terve! Näistä HSL:n hinnoista olisi vähän kerrottavaa. Terve terve, kerro vaan. Se on kun nyt on myös tuo nuorisotyöttömyys on iso puheenaihe tällä hetkellä, niin itse en ole työtön vielä ainakaan, mutta että yksi kolmasosa palkasta menee siihen kuukausilippuun. Se on siis ihan hävyttömän kalli. AB-lippu, että pääsemme kulkemaan kahdeksan kilometriä töihin joka päivä. Mikä olisi sitten hyvä hinta? No kyllä se siinä viidenkympipaikkeilla varmaan menee, että kyllä nyt vähintään alle kahden kuukauden.
25-vuotiaille pitäisi olla joku alennettu hinta. Niin eli tässä oli selkeä ehdotus, että alle 25-vuotiaille oma hinnasto. Kyllä. Kiitoksia paljon tästä ehdotuksesta. No niin, kiitoksia. Heippa! No Anja täällä, hei! Hei hei! Aattelin, että pirautanpa nyt se kerran minäkin Sinikansa Radio, kun asun täällä etelä-Suomessa ja meillä on mökki tuolla keski-Suomessa, elikkä meillä on mökki matkaa 300 kilometriä. Joka ikinen kerta joudutaan pysähtämään.
Kun meillä on vanha koira jossain tämmöisellä taukopaikalla ja täytyy sanoa, että ne on siistiytynyt hirveesti. Mutta se mikä ärsyttää on noitten rekkojen rengasrepaleet siellä tiepuolissa ja jopa ajoradalla. Elikkä me olemme kerran ajaneet Lahden Harttallinmäessä sillä tavalla, että ne rekarrepaleet olivat keskellä tietä poikki ajoradaa ja jouduttiin viemään auto korjaamalla. Että eikö tämmöiseen löytyisi minkäännäköistä neuvoa, että millä rekka kuskella olisi vaikka panostettu?.
Mustat muovisakin mihin ne kerääs ne repaleensa, ettei ne jää sinne hankaloittamaan liikennettä tai sitten tienvarsiin. - Onko näitä paljonkin tällaisia rekkarirreportteja?. - Niitä on aika paljon. Niitä on, jos ajat 300 kilometriä, niin niitä on useammassa paikkaa. Näinhän eivät välttämättä suomalaisia rekkoja, koska nekin repaleet mihinkä me ajettiin oli puolalaisista rekastajaa ja se oli vaihtamassa rengasta sitten jonkun matkan päässä tossa Lahden alapuolella. - Onko nämä lisääntyneet viime ajan?.
No mun mielestä niitä on ollut koko ajan, että en mä nyt tiedä. Kyllähän niille niitä vahinkoja sattuu, että rengas hajoaa, mutta se, että miksi ne jätetään sinne sitten muun liikenteen haitaksi ja jonkunhan ne pitää kuitenkin korjata, että tää on vähän niin kuin kysymys, että kuka sulla kotona siivoo, jos sä sotket ympäristön kodin ulkopuolella ja syntyy vaaratilanteita, että se siinä on nyt sitten loppujen lopuksi se suurin ongelma, jos ei tätä luonnontuhomista ajatella, koska ei se tule.
Kuhisintemmin mitenkään tuo luonto on sulaa eikä häviä. - Kiitos kun toi tämän asian esille. Hyvä asia, mutta jatko. - Kuin myös. Hei. - Hei täällä Irja. Repaleisin rinkaiden poistoon on Saksassa keksitty konsti, tai siis se on aivan pätevä toiminta. Siellä poliisi tulee omalla autollaan ja sitten ne kysättää liikenteen ja ajaa sitten sen pätkän siitä tiestä, missä on ilmoitettu, että olisi renkaan repaleita.
Ja he keräävät ne sitten pois ja sitten kun asia on valmis niin liikenne saa taas jatkaa menoa sillä tavalla. - Anni on rengasavoitustani ariskavaitakseni. Aikoinaan koulukyyttiä jettiin. Kyylissä ottiin ylätaksini. Roudas mäitä, ees takaisin. Kouluja koulusta vekni. Yhden päivänä keväälläni olin siinä etuumiehen penkille kato, että ei eräänäänkään.
Kuka menneoi. Ja taksistani eturengas oli eronut ja se oritti saakelillaksi erti ja meni. Vähän se könätti siihen tien vierrettä. Silloin kehti renkat mutta eivät kysyneet paikalla.
Pyheiden ripustuslenkit. Aloitamme käsittelyn napakalla sähköpostiviestillä. Verhokiinnikkeellä saa pyheliinan koukkuun. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka meillä oli lähetysnimenki kr ja viestissä oli mukana myös valokuva tästä verhokiinnikkeellä roikkuvasta pyheestä. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio.at/yle.fi.
Tuli vaan mieleen sellainen hyvä apuväline. Muistatko sellaisen kulkkoneula, elikkä hakaneula? - Hakaneula kyllä on tuttu. - Niin. Mä olen ainakin joutunut joskus laittamaan apuvälineeksi, että mä olen sen saanut tuohon nallakkoon. Niin käännät sitä pyheiliinan tai minkä tahansa reunaa kaksin kerran ja painat sen piikin siitä läpitte ja ei mitään muuta kuin paikalle. - Niin kun nyt oli kansanradio tästä pyhede, että niistä pyhenee. - Niin.
-Joo, ja minulla on just sellainen ongelma, että minulla on niin heikko näkö, että minä en näe enää oikeastaan neulonsilmäelläänkaan laittaa, niin se on ihan hyvä apu, että lukko neulaa, että sillä lailla.
-Kiitoksia, kuule tästä vinkistä. -Joo, ja kyllä minä luulen, että aika moni sen on jo älinnytti ja ainakin mitä nyt vattiisiin tulee, niin ei muuta kuin hyvät jatkossakin.
-Sitä samaa. Hei hei. -Voi voi.
-No Eeva täällä, hei. -Hei hei. -Tuota minä haluaisin antaa neuvon tälle rouvalle, joka valitteli, että pyhkeissä ei ole enää näitä niin kuin kannattimia. -Ripustus, joo. -Joo, että tuota kaupasta saa kanttinauha ja ennen vanhaakaan ei niissä pyhkeissä harvemmin ole näitä kannattimia valmiina. Mä muistan äitini ja isoäitini, neulonen niitä kanttinauhasta ja kanttinauha.
Eri väri sinäkin. Ja jos ei niitä halua sitten, on liian työlästä, niin on myöskin olemassa tämmösiä nipsuja, joissa on semmoinen lenkki, muovin lenkki, nipsu, jonka voi laittaa pyhkeen sitten mihin kohtaan haluaa ja sillä saa sitten sinne työkkoukkuun nää pyhkeet, että tällasiakin on olemassa kauppaan. -Eli mielestäni tässä ei ole tapahtunut mitään muutosta vai? -Ei, ei ole tapahtunut mitään muutosta. Mä muistan ihan selvästi, sanotaanko nyt.
neljäkymmentä, viiskyt vuotta, kuuskyt vuotta taakse päin. Itse päin seitsemänkymppinen niin minä muistan aivan selvästi äitini ja iso äitinikin ommelleen pyhkeisiin näitä kanttinauhan lenksuja niihin. Ehkä niitä on ollut jossain vaiheessa ja minullakin on pyhkeitä jo joissa on tullut jo valmiina se lenksu mutta jos ei ole pyhkeistä ja haluaa ostaa pyhkeä niin ei se ole koste eikä mikään ostaa kanttinauhaa tai sitten jos ei halua tai osaa ostaa pyhkeä.
niin niksuja saa. - Kiitoksia tästä puhelusta ja oikein hyvää asunnon jatkoa. - Siitä samaa, kiitoksia. Hei.
...heikkoja viinilitkuja. Ne ainoastaan vievät tilaa elintarvikkeilta. Viinin pitäisi olla viisasten juoma. Typerintä on se, että liian monet pysyvät eduskunnassa tästä jatkuvasti metelöimällä. Seppe Liini nimimerkki, oli lähettänyt tämän tekstin Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Katsotteko se on sanonut mieltäänkö se mies, että kalloriäkkää sitä, jotta niitä tyhjiä alastettaa eikä niitä kalata. Tai aika oteta. Kyllähän ne on syötäväksi tarkoitettu, jos niitä piilette. Minä en kyllä ymmärrä sitä allekkaan minun vashoitekkiä kallon puolesta. Kai niillä ei ole millainen tunta? Onko joku tutkinnan entiä? On kyllä minun sielittä ne kalat. Onko me sen verran, että no kyllä kalat jos kalastettaan, niin ne syypäin tai yleensä otetaan. Annetaan toisille jos ei tee.
Kyllä kiitos, hei. Tänään Kansanradios oli erittäin hyvä ohjelma noista kalastajista, kun ne koukusti vahingoittaa kalaa ja mitkä pitäisi ottaa pois koukusti ja omaa käyttöö eikä laskea enää takaisin. Se oli tosiaan hyvä ohjelma tai Kansanradio, että olisi samaa mieltä, että sellainen laki pitäisi olla, että ne kalat otetaan yleensä, mitkä vahingoittuu suustaan sillä viisiin. Hei.
Tää maitopurkki, niin Luojan Kiitus ei tarvitse ostaa enää niitä korkkilisia, että on vielä maitoa tölkissäkin semmoisessa. Miksi et sinä tykkää korkkeista? Siksi, koska vanhukset eivät saa niitä auki. Ja sitten toinen homma on se, että se korkki pyörii kuin väkkärä siinä, että kun rupeaa kaataa maitoon, niin se on hyvässä liikussa pöydällä. Kiitoksia tästä soitosta ja hyvää sunnunta jatkoa.
Kiitos. Hei. Kuulin tänään Kansanradiosta järkevän ehdotuksen, että ne, jotka menettävät mahdollisen sodan takia eniten, jos osallistuisivat puolustusmenojen kustannuksiin. On arvioitu, että 30-luvulla puolustusmenojen kustannukset nousevat yli seitsemäntoista miljardtien euroon. Eikö olisi kohtuullista, joilla on esimerkiksi omaisuutta?
Yli miljoonan, niin sitten ylimenevästä osasta maksaisivat esimerkiksi pari prosenttia veroa, joka sitten korvamerkittäisiin suoraan puolustusmenojen tattamiseen.
On pakko painaa pitkää päivää, laulaa Randelinin kake Mäntyharjulta. Työn maailmaan vievät meidät nyt seuraavat soittajat.
Suomessa taas ottaa kantaa näihin Suomessa tapahtuneisiin ja tapahtuviin tulevassa asioihin. Mä en ymmärrä sitä, minkä takia täällä saadaan rekrytoida näinä päivinä ulkomaisia rakennusalan työntekijöitä. Meillä on tuansia työttömiä rakennusalan työntekijöitä Suomessa ja niille maksetaan näitä yleensä ansiosidonnaisia päivärahoja. Siis tämä on järkyttävää. Ei muuta kuin töihin vaan.
Ja jos ei työ maistu, niin sidonnaiset ansiot pois. Kiitos, hei. - No veronmaksajavaa tässä soittelen. Nyt on kovasti media ryömytellyt tätä kolmannen sektorin, kuinka se olisi ansio tai palkkakartelia, jota tuolla pyöritellään pahalta. Se ei tuntuu näin kuin se yhtäkkiä taas esille nostettiin, mutta kyllähän meidän näytyy varmaan niitten ainakin jotka ovat olleet.
julkishallinnossa töissä niin tietää se että julkishallinnossahan poliittisella asenteella ja suuntauksella on tavattomaan suuri merkitys miten niissä julkishallinnon viroissa edetään tai miten niitä saadaan. Elikkä meillä on tää demokratia on sikäli huono homma että siellä joka tapauksessa pidetään huoli niistä jotka ovat sisäbiiriläisiä niissä tietyissä puolueissa joilla
Ja totta kai ne palkitaan sitten siitä työstä siten, että niille annetaan virkoja kunnalla, valtiolla ja yleensä semmoissa missä poliittisesti päätetään työntekijöitten rekrytoinnit.
Ja sitähän varten näihin suuriin valtionyhtiöihin esimerkiksi nimitetään poliittisesti pääjohtajat, jotka pitävät sitten huolta siitä, että se tietty yritys, jossa he johtajuuttaan käyttävät, lanseeraavat asenteensa alas henkilökuntaan saakka. Siis kyllähän tää on melkoinen juttu.
Mulla on tapana esimerkiks nää nuoret, jotka kirjoittaa ylioppilaaksi ja ovat tietysti tyytyväisiä iloisia siitä, että on yksi etappi saavutettu niin ehkä on väärinkin, mutta kyllä mulla on ollut tapana sanoa, että sitten vaan katot hyvän jäsenkirjan niin auttaa työpaikat valitaan.
Elikkä nyt kun tästä työttömyydestäkin puhutaan, niin olisi kiva ottaa selvää kuinka paljon siellä on aktiivisia poliittisia jäsenkirja ihmisiä työttömyyslistalle ja ketä ne ovat, jotka siellä nyt ovat työttöminä. Tää yhteiskunta on tämmönen. Tää on politiikka läpi joka paikkaan. Ei tää mitään ihmeellistä ole.
Kaikki työttömät ettei vähennisi ne työttömyyskuja. Tästä on marjan poimintaa sinne Lappiin. Ei tarvitsisi jätä Filippiiniltä raata niitä noukkiota. Kyllä Suomessakin on työttömyyttä että kaikki työttömät vaan sinne noukki maan marjoja. Tämä tiedoksi työviranomaisille, että siinä on teillä työllistettävää ihan riittävästi. Hei!
meikäläiseltä ja kollegoilta vei. Eli tekstin käsittelijä on ihminen, joka purkaa lääkäreitten saneluja. Ja kun nyt tämä inhimillinen ihminen sitä välistä jää pois, niin teidän oma kannassa saattaa lukea ihan mitä vaan.
Jos ei lääkäri jaksa viitsi osaa korjata sanelemaansa, elikkä sanelut ja tekstit on täysin nykyään lääkärivastuulla. Ja ajattelen tätä, että kun näitä, en ole rasisti, mutta on näitä ulkomaalaistaustaisia lääkäreitä, niin ennen tämmöinen tekstin käsittelijä pääpunasena saattoi joutua miettimään tosissaan, että mitähän tää lääkäri tässä sanelussaan tarkoittaa. Nyt on ihminen jäänyt välistä pois.
Ja kun siellä on tekoäly, joka naputtaa sitä mukaa kuin lääkäri sanelee, niin ihan oikeasti siinä oma kannassa saattaa lukea ihan mitä vaan. Elikkä esimerkiksi helikopakteeri on helikopteri tai muuta vastaa vaan. Ei mulla muuta. Moi.
Kymmeneen henkilöä pois. Ne eivät kaikki ole eräs paikalla. Jotkut eivät koskaan sano siellä mielipidettään asiasta kuin asiasta ja rahaa säästyisi paljon. Tuosta etelän vetelien ratahankkeesta sen saa heti unohtaa, mutta suupohjan rata pitää ehdottomasti korjata pian. Niin tukkirekkoja saadaan vähennettyä, kun tukit siirtyisivät junaradalle. Hyvää kesänjatkoa Kansanradion kuuntelijoille.
Tällä tavoin lukea kirjeessä, jonka meillä on lähettänyt esimerkki Vuoriston Venla. Kansanradion voi laittaa kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen. Kansanradio pl seitsemänkymmentäyhdeksän, nolla, nolla, nolla, kaksikymmentäneljä. Yleisradio kodossa lähestää terve terve terve terve. Arkadia meri menen porukasta. Mä sanoisin sen verran, että sellanenhan se porukka on kuin itse olenne.
Mutta se, että siellä on kaiken karvelta ja hamparita ynnä muita, että puolueella voisi olla joku tasokoe vaikka ainakin yleistyödoissa. Mutta mun mielestä jotain tasoa pitäisi olla. Mutta jos sen äänestyisi... - Mitä tässä kokeessa pitäisi kysyä? - Jokainen teosta. En mä sanoisi tietysti joku nauraa, jos hän on sivistävää. Mutta kyllä mun mielestä se olisi alhantyylin kieltä. Puhutaan ruma kieltä jopa melkein ja tapella ja.
Viltataan toisia ja se on kivaa. Minun mielestä kansanedustajani ei saisi olla kunnisti käyttäytyvä ikinä. - Eli ehdotat kansanedustajille tasokoetta? - Tietynlaista tasokoetta ja. - Mielenkiintoinen ehdotus. - Joo kyllä näin kuulen. Päätöksentekijät, jotka ovat professoriit ja muut, tietävät miten ne tarkoitetaan. Me olemme tyytyväisiä siihen, mitä hyvä meillä täällä Suomessa vielä on. Sinulla on hieno radio, hieno radio vaikka mun miehellä ei ole helppo kuunnella.
Ahaa kiitos kun kuuntelet ja kiitos paljon tästä ehdotuksesta ja oikein hyvää pyhäpäivän jatkoa. - Kiitos ja samoin sulle. - Kiitos, hei hei. - Kyllä tuo Harri Harri Kimmo sais oikein kymmenen pistettyä papukaa ja menikin kun sanotte kyllä. Noita hallia jo on aivan tarpeeksi, jotta nekin tähän pitää halliihin panna kun ei niitä tarvita kun niitä on kyllä.
Mutta katso kun hyväveli pyytää niin kyllä hyväveli antaa tämä orpo on aivan hyvä niin että kun se antaa hyväveli kun pyytää. Täältä pojanmaalta moi.
- No niin nytkä se alkaa tuo korruptio mellominen eikä sitä hiivatti ole mittaan muuta tuolla hallituksessa. Omiileinen jakkaa ei siitä ei pääse mihinkään. Oma suu on lähempänä kuin kontti suu.
Se on semmoista hommaa ja niin retuu perällä kaikki kerta kaikkiaan. Eihän tuosta tuntuu loppua kyllä kerta kaikkiaan ollenkaan. Ja niin epärehellistä touhua että ei kestä kyllä kohta päivänvaloa.
- Ajattelipa tässä talvalla todellakin kipeitä päätöksiä laittaa 45 miljoonaa semmoiseen hankkeeseen mistä on mitään takeita eikä tietoa. Ja sitten Vapaavuori väittää kuinka sitten tulee ikkunoista ja ovista tulee sitä aakerityöllisiä lisää ja kauheasti tulee kaikki hotelleihin ja raviintonoihin ja muihin. Tämmösiä aikaa rahaa ei ole mihinkään muualle sitten tuommoiseen turhan päivästen. Parein on rupeaa olemaan Suomi täyttei käyttäkää niitä loi.
- Joo JKH Tampereelta moro. Eli näin jos kumarrat oikeaan niin pyllistät vasemmalle ja jos kumarrat vasemmalle pyllistät oikealle. Totemus, viisaus ja noin päin pois.
- Mistäs tämmöinen tuli meille?
- Joo kuuluteli tuossa vähän politiikkaa ohjelmaa ja tätä kansanradio siinäkin oli pikkusen politiikkaa ja eilen ei ole kuulin paljon politiikkaa niin siitä tää kaikki lähti tuli vain yhtäkkiä mieleen tämmönen.
- Kiitokset tästä toteamuksesta ja hyvää sunnuntajatkoa sinne Pirkanmaalle.
- Kiitos ja samoin sinulle hyvää sunnuntajatkoa. Hei hei.
- Hellou jos haluat rikastua ryhdy politiikoksi. Siellä on ne miljonäärit kaikki tuolla politiikassa. Sinne ne menee kaikki meidän verorahat mitä me yritämme maksaa. Ei ne ainakaan vanhustenhoitoomme eikä lasten terveytään. Sella lailla.
- Sella lailla. Seuraavaksi siirrymme tiiviimmin sosiaali- ja terveysaiheiden hellään huomaan. Ennen puheluitaan paikallaan muistuttaa että Kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjantai kello 21. Jos merkkaat sydämenkuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellonkuvasta niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Tuna jota vankolle korville kuulla järkikommentteja Kansanradiossa näistä pillerikaappiasta jota lääkäreiksikin kutsutaan. Tähän liittyen muistuu mieleen professorilla se lehtose ilmaisema huoli mediassa. Pari vuotta sitten hän pääsi osua härän silmään eli naolan kantaa kun sanoi että Suomeen on luotu tehoton helvetin kone ja sen seurauksena suomalaisten eliäodote on huonontunut. Tätä unkeko ne haitalliset pillerit.
Sinne sinne ei aurinko paistaa läski voi ja punainen maito käyttöön ja sokeriötöt kaljat namut ja pikaruoka sinne helvetin koneeseen. Minne ei ala lääkefirmoja rikastuttajaksi. Tää laitetaanpa suitset suuhun tälle terveyspolitiikalle ja järkikäteen. Terveisin entinen meierimies. Lättäkää julkiseen tietoon semmoinen että lääkäreille ja sairaanhaitteille on vaikeeluvelvollisuus.
potilastiedosta. Me tulemme meetinkiä tuon pitkin kylänraikkeen, levittelemme kaikki ja jopa luetetaan ja kopioidaan ihmiset, potilastietää jaetaan niitä tuonne. Ja kun tässä on kyseessä mielisairat sairaat, jotka tehdään myöskin, niin ei tajua, että mikä on vaikeolo ja saassa pidettävä asia.
Tämmöinen nykyinen oppositio. Puheista päätellen kaikki ongelmat poistuvat. Raa on, elikkä ei kannata olla vammaiset vanhukset ja muut vähäosa kannata olla huolissaan. Elikkä sieltä on niin paljon ryhyä turvallisuuskuun kunnalle, että te madette Lindt vanhia ja me tää vihervasori puoluetta, elikkä vasemmassa liittyvää vihreitä ja näitäni. Elikkä kissanpäivät on kansalaisille edessä. Kaikki tulee kuntoon. Puhkatsa sitä luokkaa. Uskokoon ken haluaa. Minä en usko näihin pelle puolueisiin ollenkaan. Ei muuta. Kiitos. Hei.
Viime jaksossa ei huudettu esiintyvältä yhtyeltä paranoidia, vaan kysyttiin tuon laulun suomenkielistä esittäjää.
Olin lisäksi moni muukin toi viestissään esiin tämän froikkareiden laulun. Toinen suosittu vastaus oli eläkeläistyhtyeen Hullun Jenkka -kappale. Itselleni uusi tuttavuus tuli Peksiltä. Hän kirjoittaa WhatsApp-viestissään näin:
Erkki ja tähti. Näin meille kertoi WhatsApp-viestissä Peksi lisäyksenä hänen viestiinsä, että tuon suomennoksen nimi on Polaroid. Meille kansanradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tällaisia tekstikommentteja että myös äänimuotoisia, jollaisia on mukana tässä ohjelmassa parikin kappaletta. Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551.
Viisi neljä kuusi neljä. Nyt siirrymme siivouksen maailmaan.
Niistä mennään suoraan pitkään linja huoneissa ja kaikki muut pienet tilat. Pitkään linja tarvittaa eteenpäin. Eteenpäin isoissa avarissa tiloissa ja huoneessa sitten tulla itseään kohtaan. Eli peruutetaan. Ja huoneeseen selvoiko se on potilaat tai mikä tahansa niin kyllä sitä aina kuulee näkeä ihmiset kun liikkuu takaa ja ne väistelee ja kuulee.
Melkein kolmekymmentä vuoden nää siivouskokemukset on niin. Kuinka tuorta tietoa sulla on? Tämähän on ihan tuoretta normaalitietoa. Tuo sairaaloissa niin nehan ne... Eli olette edelleen tehokassa? Nyt me olemme eläkkeellä. No niin, joo. Että sinä kun itse olet ollut työelämässä niin näin on. Kyllä, joo. Se on ihan kuule koulussaikka jo 90-luvulla niin isoissa tiloissa tällä listalla.
Ootko monta vuotta ollut eläkkeellä? Nyt minä olen ollut parikymmentä vuotta kohtaan. No niin, selvä. Mutta ei nuo siivousvinkis. Ne eivät muutu mihinkään. Aivan. Kiitos tästä tiedosta ja oikein hyvää sunnunta jatkoa. Samoin sulle joo. Hyvää kesäjatkoa. Siitä samaa. No ei hei.
ekonomia ja turvallisuus lisääntyy myös siinä työssä. Täällä alan ammattilainen huuteloo, että myös moppia täyttäessä siistimistyössä me emme enää käytä märkää menetelmää juuri laisinkaan, ainoastaan nihkeää ja kosteaa sekä joskus myös pelkkää kuivaa.
Näin ollen emme mene siis selkä edelläpäin vaan käytämme silmiä ja kuljetaan etuperin. Jess! Hepsustaa!
Esimerkiksi sairaaloissa on vaara törmätä jo ennestään sairaisiin potilaisiin ja toiseksi kyse on myös omasta turvallisuudesta. Se on tavattoman kallista kun putoat rappusista ja loukkaat itsesi. Mitä tulee ikkunanpesuun niin nykyisistä sanomalehdistä irtoaa mustetta ja ikkuna jää likaiseksi. Ikkunat kannattaa kuivata puuvilla pyyhkeillä eikä edes nukkaa ikkunoihin.
Tämän WhatsApp-viestin meillä on lähettänyt Henna ennen runoja kerron Kansanradion puhelinnumeron. Se on 08 0 0 1 5 4 6 4 ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton ja muistutuksena että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmisvastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Ikkaari täältä ikäärisistä. Minä kuulin että nyt on se runoje suven päivä niin ajattelin että pitää lausua pieni runo kaikille Suomen naisille. Se on tämä runon nimi on harkipäivän romantiikka.
Ensimmäiset pakokaasut sekoittuu. Kollikissa laulu jostain kaupungille kantautuu. Herätystä kellot soittaa töihin riennät joutuisaan. Asunnosta vuokratusta muuten lähtet kokonaan. Lapset kesken uniansa tarhaa viedä täytynee naimamiehen alushousut sängyn alta löytyneet.
Alavi soittelee. Hyvää täivää. Luen runoni liian usein. Liian usein kätkemme kaiken sen kaiken josta voisi olla onnellinen. Liian usein kiireesti eteenpäin. Me juoksemme kiirehdimme. Mitä teetkin? Tee huolella harkiten niin kuin teet turvat päiväsi huomisen. Alavi kuulemme kohta asiaa vielä ainakin kuorikatteesta. Ennen viimeisiä puheilua.
Hyvää valvonta. Minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää. Koiviston Lauri Kiittää kumartaa Kansan Radio jälleen viikon päästä. Seuraa kysymys minkä takia julkisiin esimerkiksi kaupungin puistoihin levitetään kuorikatetta suuripino ja sitä ei levitetä viikkokausiin. Tällaisen ilmiön olen huomannut tässä toistui joka kevät ja alkukesä Tampereen Tuomiokirkon kirkkopuistosta.
Tuossa kulmen kuusi puun väliin saapuu valtava läjäkuorikatetta ja se seisoo ja seisoo ja seisoo ja vasta yleensä sitten kesäkuun jälkeen jo heinäkuun puolella niin sitä katetta aletaan levitellä ja ei kerralla vaan uusissa että se kasa siinä sitten edelleen jatkaa sitä ulemassa uloaan. En tiedä en ole tähän vastausta löytänyt. Tietääkö joku? Erkolaimainen Turusta. Täältä Petsilien juusoilla tämmöinen muistutus että.
Miksi te naurat nyt aivan tyhjälle? Vanha sanota sanoo että mies se tulee räkään nokastakin muttei tyhjän naurajasta. Ja jos se tämä tyhjän nauraminen ei lopu niin minä lopetan koko ajan kuuntelu siihen ja sillä selvä.
Ihminen herää tokkurassa pyhä aamuna. Uutisten lukija sanoo alko on auki. Nyt äkkiä viinakauppa.